well advert auslay getting his first
start of the season he's had uh really
brief stints with the cubs each the last
two years combined 10 appearances six
starts and a 454 earned run average
had a rough spring i mean nine earned
runs in seven and two thirds innings
daniel vogelback steps into the batters
box got some power though
and he misses low so bulba back the
brewers first base runner here tonight
draws the walk
al zaleh facing yelich for the first
time
so after falling behind two strikes
early yeliches worked the count full
3-2 on the way and into right field base
hit
bogelback makes the turn and heads to
third base
so first and third for milwaukee here in
the opening frame with one down yeah got
a hanging curve ball and a full
count able to get it by rizzo which is
an easy thing to do
one of the best the defensive first
baseman in the league
and here's that breaking pitch just
hangs up for christian who gets a good
swing at it all right so yellow at first
bogle back at third
travis shaw the batter hit in the air
left field
well struck peterson back warning track
gone
travis shaw with a three run a home run
the brewers
needed that one big time in this first
inning gotta get on the board they did
it today
travis shaw taking it to the opposite
field the wind's blowing out to left
at wrigley tonight gets it up in the air
and it just flew on out of here
another breaking ball slider that just
kind of spun up there
good contact spins up there and hangs
out over the plate where he can get his
arms extended
not the location he wants definitely not
the result you want buddy peralta
on the hill first start here of the
young season and making his
second career start against the cubs
eight ninth appearance
overall two and one a five forty earned
run average had a really good
spring 23 strikeout 13 and two thirds
innings
making his second appearance this year
he pitched opening day out of the
bullpen
two innings six punch outs so appearance
number two on the season
first start game five
the 1-0 bouncing ball to short orios to
second
long to first double play six four three
twin killing quickly two down nobody on
and the batter is anthony rizzo there
you go
freddie's typically not a ground ball
guy he's more the fly ball
strikeout tight pitcher with that high
fast ball
he's out there for his second inning of
work
the double play helped him out in the
first inning so
it's chris bryant now the cleanup hitter
to lead off
in the second inning for chicago oh
check swing he went at the slider
another strikeout for freddie peralta
that's his
second of the game another breaking ball
brian
trying to hold up just like rizzo tried
to hold up couldn't do it
i tell you when you see a lot of check
swings you know hitters are baffled by
freddie's movement on a strike tobias
high and tight
shaking his head and is upset with the
brewers dugout somebody said something
i was stirring it up a little bit
telling freddie we're good
no problem a reminder of last night when
contreras got hit
and peralta gets the called strike three
that was borderline right at the bottom
of the strike zone it had the plate
marvia's pulls it up and
i thought it was a strike as well that's
out number two two down and it brings up
omar narvaez narvaez puts a charge into
one out to left center
bye by baseball omar narvaez stay hot
his second home run of the season his
second
in as many nights and the brewers take a
four to nothing lead
that one a big fly fast ball away goes
right with it but look at the contact
that perfect swing good
balance perfectly keeping that bat and
that barrel
in the swing path and in the strike zone
great to see omar narvaez swinging it
rizzo bryant and peterson the trio two
up here for chicago
one two on the way and a strikeout for
peralta again that slider
how about that nasty pitch that might be
the best one he's thrown
he threw a good one to get it happy look
at this one my goodness 981
down in the knees milwaukee leading four
nothing
bottom of the fourth with one away 3-2
on the way
this one hammered into left field falls
in for the first
base hit by chicago tonight and this one
gets past yelich
all the way into the corner and brian's
going to be held up at third base
yelich came over that sidewall can be
very tricky
and he misplayed the ball it rolled all
the way down the line into the corner
and bryant has a one out triple two and
two now with one out base is empty
top six here comes
and that one is
oh nice play david great stretch by
rizzo
bodie showing off the range
he ran a long way to backhand that ball
and made a difficult
sidearm running throw going back to
first
so he's running away from where the
throne went beautiful play by
bodhi ma'am his shots obviously had a
knock and bodhi says no sir
denied well freddie peralta's knight is
done
it looks like he has cemented his spot
in the brewers rotation for a while a
lot of swings and misses on the breaking
ball he kind of feathered that one in
there took a little off of it that was
part of his
uh skill set here tonight the ability to
change speeds with that breaking ball
but a lot of stuff working from the
knees
down and we talked so much about his
elevated fastball but
trying to change the script a little bit
with all those breaking pitches eight
strikeouts and five innings allowing
just the one hit
as daniel robertson gets to hit for the
first time came on defensively
to replace travis shaw
[Applause]
that one up the middle bode sliding stop
throw to first
rizzo great play his second of the night
as bodhi steals a hit from robertson
and some help on the back end by rizzo
second baseman
sliding to backhand the ball off balance
made a one-hop throw to rizzo
just in time to get robertson what a
play
last licks for the cubs down four
nothing been held to one hit
brewers have never no hit or won
hit the cops
saying two times
is upset he's gotten hit in the head and
he's got hit in the back
the bullpen is empty the bench is empty
jason hayward
ran out as a as a peacemaker and made
sure that things started to settle down
and this one to robertson bobbled it but
the throw
is in time and this one is over
at wrigley field as the brewers win it
four to nothing over the chicago cubs
and the losing streak is over the
brewers are back